the female manager would like
because i smoked back then and she would
like make me walk like to the other end
of the mall
yeah and i was just like god i can't do
this
i just can't do this anymore you know
and that's when bob remember when bob
was living um
above the comedy store yeah oh yeah is
that where we're at
yeah yeah yeah wait i was walking
together then mm-hmm yeah
when he lived over like sunset junction
he lived in a really small apartment
over in silver lake oh that's right
yeah that's when i first met him what
are you saying george
the dumpster yeah yep no no no this is
post dumpster
the og dumpster is when all of us live
there
on the third floor and remember bob
booked that
ibm global the big one that that the
cold or not campaign yeah
did you think he was a big shot then
when he booked it he flashed me i
remember he showed me his check
oh you showed us what he did
we were on melrose and he goes he goes
and then you know this is when he um
remember
how bob loved diesels yeah yeah oh no oh
yes we would go the diesel the diesel
jeans
because i mean we thought that in high
school you thought diesel was like the
top-of-the-line most expensive thing
right
oh he had every pair yeah at every part
but so we're on melrose and then
he goes out of his pocket he goes oh
this is the way i do it dude
he goes like this this is the way i'm
doing it dude that's bobby yeah
how are you doing it yeah how are you
doing yeah this is
you know what i mean does that sound
accurate
it sounds it couldn't be more accurate
this is the way i do it
how are you doing something like that
you put me in a rage
i can't stand but you know what
god always gives us like counters to
those it's like a hundred thousand
dollars
so much oh my god so let me not forget
the trajectory
that's when okay so this is he we're in
the dumpster and then
he got that money yeah and he moved like
two floors down
and that's what the apartment you're
talking about so it wasn't the dumpster
oh you guys lived in that hole yeah we
all lived
at the dumpsters like us and like 10
skateboarders and
just random people and then bob got the
code or not campaign
yeah and then he moved down he got his
own spot
fancy boy you you booked something too
though at that time you were not did you
have a starburst commercial you were in
a massive commercial
yeah the starstruck starburst
that was a really funny that was a good
one that was a good one you know how
they're uh
re-running like old ones that were
successful back then that's one that
they should do again
you liked it that one was a good one
where you make the baby cry yeah hey
jimmy come
see the baby what was the accent for
that
it was a chinese hey come and see the
baby
that was rich i don't know i would see
the baby come see the baby
the baby and i remember they had it like
um because i kept missing my mark
and then so they're like i had to like
act like
you know i'm doing my own thing and then
i had to hit this mark and then
out of my pocket have a sour starburst
and then
put it in my mouth and then by the time
i got to the baby i had to like make the
face
[Laughter]
and then yeah but you know that was hard
to book because
every time i got i kept coming back for
the call back
there's a another like young like asian
kid
so i'm like oh my god and you know how
like shallow i got
you know how shallow they were the
whatever the people the um
the casting people on the last one
they brought another kid like who didn't
even go through the other
auditions and then i overheard them
we're in front of the vista theater
remember the vista
i do yeah we're eating um cut lemons
and then i remember one of them saying
uh pic
pick the other one uh his hair is more
like bruce lee's
everyone bruce lee and you do that
there's only reference right they're
and so i heard that and i'm like oh this
is how it works
wow oh that was your audition wow that
was my last audition that was like my
whatever the last call back
okay and then you booked it yeah
that's how that's how i do it that's how
you do that's how you
no i didn't make a hundred thousand
dollars
i didn't make a hundred thousand dollars
no but you know you were doing
commercials weren't you
i did i did like with aqua right didn't
because bob got everyone either
originally he did
we were all uh wrapped by aqua at one
point i was here for like
six years you know who has to guardo oh
god
i remember i like gargoyle yeah i've
always liked cardiff yeah okay i love
cardo
um but everyone bobby always just pulls
everyone i think into the same thing
everyone see yeah i think his
ex-girlfriend too
oh yeah because i think she wanted to go
jules is just coming out of the corner
every five minutes
quitting are you she is little what's
this now
what is this beef beef steak wow beef
steak
who's making all this oh jules has been
cooking dude
full time she's